Interest rates are how much money costs.
Ali's money doesn't cost very much.
People are going to use more of it.
It's pretty straight forward.
So,
um,
it takes the breaks off things
because it's less expensive to risk.
I mean,
that's why government to
manipulate the interest rates,
right?
When,
when they want to stimulate the economy,
they drive down the interest rates to
make money cheaper so that people spend
more of it.
So it certainly contributed
to the housing boom,
although I don't think it contributed
nearly as much as crookedness did.
It was a combination
of radical innovation,
which is always dangerous,
although also necessary
and regulatory failure.